nvidia's next generation of video cards
is here and i have the rtx 3080
and i put it to the test for this review
do we love it
does it live up to the hype is it as
powerful as nvidia says it is
well let's dig into all of that first
let's establish our methodology
with our situation working from home we
had access to limited resources but
managed to put together a well-suited
test bench
this includes an intel core i7 10700
9k cpu but clocked at 4.7 gigahertz
16 gigabytes of corsair ram a samsung
960 pro nvme ssd
and a 1 000 watt sea sonic platinum psu
to juice the system
our test included three video cards the
rtx 3080 of course
the rtx 2080 ti and the base rtx 2080
all founders editions with nvidia
claiming very high performance jumps
compared to the rtx 2080 and with the
rtx 2080 ti being the most powerful
consumer grade card of that generation
it makes sense to see how the rtx 3080
stacks against them
in particular keep in mind when looking
at the results that the 3080 starts
around 700
while the 2080 ti goes for upwards of a
thousand dollars and the 2080
hovers around 700 as well as for
benchmarks we use
10 different pc games to compare
performance between r3 video cards
these include metro exodus control
shadow of the tomb raider
wolfenstein youngblood final fantasy 15
final fantasy xiv shadowbringers red
dead redemption 2
assassin's creed odyssey horizon zero
dawn and forza horizon 4.
modern games some more graphically
demanding than others but also a good
variety to test things like rtx ray
tracing
and dlss super sampling as well as raw
performance metrics
in this video we focus on performance at
max settings
and nvidia graphics features turned on
when available
at both 4k and 1440p resolutions
and we measured each card in average fps
calculated by the game's benchmark tools
keep in mind that you always have
options to adjust graphics features
to improve fps output in your own
situations with the important technical
details
out of the way let's get into some
numbers lots
of numbers metro exodus is one of the
most demanding games out there and it
includes full ray tracing
options as well as dlss and the built-in
benchmark is a good stress test
at 4k with every setting maxed average
frame rate output came out to 51.6
fps for the rtx 3080. this comes out to
a 24.6
increase over the 2080 ti and a 63.8
percent improvement
over the 2080. at 1440p average frame
rate came out to 67.2 fps for the 3080
a 20.4 percent increase and 54.8 percent
increase over the 2080 ti and 2080
respectively
control is visually enticing demanding
and full of graphics options
we turned every ray tracing option on
maxed out settings
and used the lss since control doesn't
have a built-in benchmark we made our
own by running through an early section
of the old house that was easily
repeatable and used fraps to record the
average
fps at 4k average frame rate came out to
64 fps
on the rtx 3080. this makes for a 35
jump from the 2080 ti and a whopping
103.2 percent increase over the 2080.
at 1440p average frame rate came out to
104.6
fps for the 3080 which marks a 27.1
percent
and 59.7 percent increase over the
respective 2080 ti
and 2080 cards shadow of the tomb raider
remains a graphical showcase with lush
detailed environments
and features ray tracing and dlss
running at 4k with everything maxed
the rtx 3080 got a 70 fps average
these are 22.8 percent and 62.8 percent
increases over the 2080 ti and 2080
respectively
running at 1440p the 3080 hit an average
of 100 fps
which comes out to 16.3 percent and 49.5
increases over the respective cards
wolfenstein youngblood isn't the most
graphically demanding game
but we can measure performance in the id
tech 6 engine
with ray tracing and dlss we use the
riverside benchmark run
with everything at max settings at 4k we
got an average frame
rate of 117 fps for the 3080.
this result makes for a jump of 31.5
percent
and 69.6 against the 2080 ti
and 2080. at 1440p average frame rate
came out to 171 fps
on the 3080 meaning smaller gains of
18.8 percent
and 45 over the 2080 ti and 2080.
final fantasy 15 is a visual powerhouse
with a robust benchmark test
while it doesn't have ray tracing it has
other nvidia features including dlss
note that this benchmark does not give
average fps
rather produces a total score at 4k with
max settings
the rtx 3080 scored 7281
this comes out to 20.1 percent and 35.2
performance increases against the 2080
ti
and 2080. for 1440p the final fantasy 15
bench does not allow dlss
so here we just use the high quality
settings preset
and here the rtx 3080 scored 11
381 which comes out to 14.2 percent
and 36.4 performance increases
well what can i say shadowbringers is
the best expansion for an
all-time favorite game in final fantasy
14.
you know i had to do it to him there's
also a free benchmark tool out there
this one also produces a score rather
than average fps
at 4k max the rtx 3080 scored
14 138 indicating performance jumps of
22.1 percent
and 58 against the 2080 ti
and 2080. at 1440p we have the 3080
scored at 17626
which shows minimal gains over its 2080
counterparts
here we see a lower spec game like final
fantasy 14
reach its upper limit of gpu reliance
and become more cpu bound with minor
performance increases
between cards red dead redemption 2 is
certainly graphically demanding with a
slew of options to help tweak your
performance
we turned everything up to max but just
went with taa for anti-aliasing
at 4k average frame rate came out to
43.1 fps
for the 3080 which marks increases of
16.2 percent
and 52.3 percent over the 2080 ti
and 2080. at 1440p average frame rate
came out to 62.9 fps
with the 3080 and these numbers indicate
increases of 21
and 61.3 percent over the respective
2080 cards
assassin's creed odyssey remains a
visually stunning and demanding game
though it tends to be cpu heavy it's
still important to see how high-end
video cards fare here
at 4k the 3080 got an average of 62 fps
which comes out to respective gains of
19.2 percent
and 51.2 percent in performance using
1440p
the 3080 hidden average of 78 fps
which is a decent improvement but not
significant compared to other tests
like final fantasy 14 assassin's creed
odyssey at 1440p
starts a show where the workload leans
heavier into the cpu
limiting the effectiveness of a beefy
gpu
horizon zero dawn just got ported to pc
with mixed results
it's had some improvements since its
launch and has a decent benchmark tool
to stress our video cards though
at 4k average fps counts came out to 75
fps
for the 3080 and these results show 31.6
percent
and 66.7 increases from the two other
cards
using 1440p average frame rate was 109
fps with the 3080
coming out to 13.5 percent and 39.7
jumps for the 3080 over the respective
cards
and finally forza horizon 4 a beautiful
open world racing game with a wildly
detailed benchmark tool
at 4k and everything maxed including
msaa the 3080 hit an average of 96
fps which is a jump of 28
and 50.8 over the 2080 ti
and 2080. going to 1440p
average framerate came out to 129 fps
for the 3080
which comes out to 15.2 percent and 35.8
against the respective cards so after
all those numbers
benchmarks and graphic settings the
takeaway is this
the rtx 3080 is a powerful card with big
generational jumps
especially when considering its 700 msrp
the rtx 3080 shows decent gains over the
rtx
2080 ti which is a card that came out
the gate
much more expensive and the 3080 shows
significant improvements over the base
rtx 2080.
nvidia's claim of up to twice as fast as
the 2080 is
a bit of a stretch although this was
true and a big game like control
nvidia tempered expectations a little
bit by saying we'd see closer to 60
percent gains
and that much is true based on our
results and that improvement is nothing
to scoff at
however whether or not you should buy an
rtx 3080 depends on how you want to run
your games
it's your best option for 4k capable of
60fps
at max settings with little to no
compromises
however the improvements tend to taper
off at 1440p
regardless it's a better value than the
2080 ti
and 2080 at this point even if the gains
aren't as apparent at 1440p
but if you don't really care about 4k or
you aren't trying to push your high
refresh rate 1440p monitor to its limits
i consider the rtx 3080 overkill
for now if those aspects aren't your jam
you probably want to keep an
eye on the upcoming rtx 3070. either way
if you're still on a gtx 10 series card
this might be a good generation to hop
on with great features like dlss for
simultaneous image quality
and performance improvements and ray
tracing which is increasingly relevant
in games
not to mention the boost in raw
performance so yes while the rtx 3080 is
an incredible card
just make sure it's something that
you're actually getting the most out of
for a little more in-depth analysis be
sure to check out my full written review
on gamespot.com thanks for watching
[Music]
wow